how dirty is your man 97% impossible no
not enough
I said not enough 100% impossible damn
son 1% impossible damn it
million percent impossible how dirty is
your leg can you pass this test
[Music]
this is brilliant just make a stupid
[ __ ] face and add a picture to the
left let's the limit let me do that got
him got him in AD circles circles and
arrows more circles more titties you
know if I uploaded a video like this it
would [ __ ] get flagged so fast cuz
you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] so we're
gonna keep it nice and clean anyway
let's begin the test you folks at home
it can play along okay alright so far I
don't see anything wrong it's just two
girls hanging out oh my god she's
fingering oh wait no it's her leg
there's nothing wrong with two girls
fingering
that's disgusting prayers they've
changed things they change
hallelujah whoa they're just cuddling
okay
they're just cuddling squirting shower
spray yeah that's that's always out how
I shower just like it like it all to
rain down on my face that's what hey
anal beads how is that a dog how is that
a dog that's a hairy dick that ain't no
dog I actually don't see it in this one
is it P what the [ __ ] is it with legs I
don't understand they freak me the [ __ ]
out okay alright this is this is this is
[ __ ] we need to step it up a bit
thirty pictures that prove you have a
dirty mind I don't have a dirty mind
that's a girl's [ __ ] honestly I don't
know what else it could
it's our elbow what why do they look so
similar why did God make elbows and ass
cracks so similar coincidence I think no
someone has a weird fetish moving on
oh my god I can't look at this I can't
look at mites yeah this is disgusting I
wouldn't I refuse I am blocking it with
a microphone I do not see it I swear now
that's either some weird ass looking
titties or I love her face I don't know
what I'm looking at is it is it like
this like elbow is just elbows the
elbows don't really its outbursts it's
out those oh what's a corridor it's it's
just a corner well might see a place I
was just looking at it I think the real
challenge here should be if you can jerk
off to any one of these you can mind
[ __ ] yourself enough and be like yeah
yeah this is some good [ __ ]
oh my god it's an arm oh my god what the
[ __ ] you know if I if I ever get the
chance to take a photo like this I would
right before I click I'd be like thank
you Lord for making arms look so [ __ ]
weird then I would never share it to
anyone I would just keep it to myself
and you know hey Felix whatever happened
to that picture
these ladies are really comfortable with
their friends they're manspreading and
that's disgusting their woman's
spreading oh I see it's okay when girls
do it disgusting
that have been gonna make a Netflix show
out of that a really intimate massage
place Jesus Christ no what the [ __ ] was
wrong with the world mama people livin
like that's in vagina I've always wanted
someone of a job I didn't think they
would be this [ __ ] horrific no pastor
please what is that what is that what I
don't want to go too close what is that
thing that's his dick what else could it
be either an either a snake it's that or
a snake I don't comment down below if
you know what it is cuz I don't know
what nothing like a good old family
picture where the daughter is uh she's
I'm she either has very disproportionate
arms or her hand is down to her dad's
pants she's punching her [ __ ] I don't I
am so confused I didn't think it would
be this perverse you know I'm pretty
perverted and I'll admit I'm not afraid
oh you have a dirty mind yeah yeah I do
I think we all do moving on I don't see
it I see it I see it
what the [ __ ] is that thing that can't
be faked what is that it's the oh my god
it's the bus yeah this reminds me of
when Lady Gaga had the rumor of her
having a penis do you remember that I
remember when I saw that the first time
and I'm like that's a dick
that's clearly a dick there it is that's
a penis why is hurt it showing Shelby oh
never mind
it's your arm god damn Shelby all is
showing her titties Shelby why is your
tits showing can you tuck it back in at
least for the goddamn Facebook picture
okay I don't see oh my god never mind
where does his penis has come from I I'm
starting to develop a theory in my mind
about ghosts penises
I'm writing it right now the theory is
that girls have penises that will only
appear during certain Facebook pictures
I got about 500 more pages to go but
that's the intro
it's another ghost penis ghost penis
this one I don't get I've seen this one
a million times it's an ass crack I
don't see the problem
I am seeing a vagina right now I don't
know what you're seeing I am seeing a
vagina goes penis strikes again oh my
god it's a fruit it's a tomato
it's the vagina what the [ __ ] is that oh
it's there every picture is like was it
oh this is slut-shaming okay there's
nothing wrong with two women touching
each other this one I remember first
time I saw this one I was like why would
you do that to that baby [ __ ] this
picture it took me [ __ ] ages you got
to look pretty bad if your [ __ ]
shoulder it looks like your [ __ ] head
and combined look like an [ __ ] can
you imagine being that baby growing up
um what what is it's an elbow [ __ ]
elbows why do they look so weird but
it's not an elbow was the arm arm rest
arm crack what see I'm just tired now I
like just [ __ ] giggling like I hey it
looks like a penis see it happen again
brothers [ __ ]
haha well Kathy you know Catholic
priests what can I say you know when
people find like Jesus in toast and
stuff like that if I ever find Jesus in
a toast I wouldn't care however if I
find a penis in the in a Clementine
that's how I know God is real why who
put their dog up somewhere you pet it
and you make this [ __ ] face like it
doesn't exist
Jesus oh it's a pig
you didn't see that that was a pig or to
[ __ ] you dirty-minded son of a [ __ ]
come on tell me honestly did you did you
pass the dirty mind test only a thousand
percent can't make it share this video
if you failed on your Facebook be sure
to LIKE share and also post this on your
email listen I'm just trying to abroad
in my audience bed it seems like we're
running a little too high and check out
another video right here if you have a
dirty mind leave a comment down below
[Music]
god